[Music]
the florida department of education
announced this week that it has rejected
dozens of math textbooks submitted by
publishers saying they contain
prohibited topics or unsolicited
strategies including critical race
theory
now you might be wondering how could a
math book promote critical race theory
well so was that so we got our hands on
one of the books in question
so let's take a look and see if they're
right
okay let me take a look here right here
it says
matthew has one million dollars sarah
has two million dollars okay pretty
normal so far why were matthew and sarah
turned down for a mortgage
oh my god maybe they are right wait
let's look at the next question
okay
a school bus is heading down the highway
with 30 students and one driver how many
people on the bus have inherited
generational wealth
oh my gosh you guys
for once i don't think they're
exaggerating okay let me see what else
is in here
carla has two cans of peaches and two
cans of beans why don't any of the
grocery stores in her neighborhood sell
fresh produce
[ __ ] that's a good question
okay let's see
freddy needs a quarter pound of stuffing
for every pound of turkey why is freddy
celebrating a holiday that glorifies
colonialism
okay
if train a is heading east at 80 miles
per hour and train b is heading west at
100 miles per hour why is no one on
either train thinking about the
problematic way in which america built
its railroads
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what a
silly little sketch this was huh
we have fun
but the bad news is this is a real news
story these [ __ ] are really out
here banning books
they are using fear mongering to keep
american children from lose using
learning the truth
and the truth is
two plus two equals racism
wow i guess crt is everywhere
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you